ce sont des images impressionnantes
d'une foule compacte de 500 personnes
qui se sont pressées devant l'entrée
d'un magasin lidl à orgeval dans les
yvelines
la raison une promotion exceptionnelle
sur la console playstation 4 qui pour
l'occasion était affichée au prix de 95
euros au lieu de 300 euros une réduction
spectaculaire qui n'a pas manqué de
faire son petit effet trente minutes
avant l'ouverture du magasin des
centaines de clients étaient déjà
agglutinés devant le supermarché en
attendant l'ouverture des portes
mais devant la masse compacte
d'individus la gendarmerie a dû
intervenir pour rétablir l'ordre alors
scène de cohue chez lidl après une
promotion sur une console de jeux
choquer ou pas choquer alors je vais
vous dire quelque chose
mine de rien on a engueulé bernard
montiel mai l'enseigne a été cité
plusieurs fois dans le magnifique alors
alors la furie des dites nous oui alors
c'est aient déstocké c'était lors de la
coupe du monde qu'ils avaient sorti ça
effectivement mal envoyé ils ont fait
c'est eux qui sont à plaindre c'est
l'ouverture de ce magasin à orgeval
vous savez qu'ils avaient déjà fait
cette promo à epernay d'un tonneau de
magasins à 80 euros moins cher sans le
dire ce s'est vendu tranquillement sans
bordel là ils ont fait exprès pour faire
le mien l'exemple il était très
justement ici faire d'abord aux mots je
comprends bien s'y risquent
effectivement il ya une semaine de cela
ils ont fait la même opération mais
encore une fois sans le son le préciser
sans le dire parce que c'est une
opération de 10 de déstockage sur pleins
produits dont celui ci à 80 euros et là
il n'y a pas eu de débordement la porte
au nez un débordement c'est parce qu'un
employé a tweeté la photo en lisant
demain il va ya voir ça et du coup tout
le monde la suisse sont libérales et du
coup ça a créé bon cette hausse est à
compter avec en tournée promo
exceptionnelle où le dit pas alors oui
vous avez raison mais bien moi je sais
c'est quoi ça alors oui monsieur mais
c'est moi je trouve ça choquant ce
qu'ils font à des radiations sur
bittorrent choqué par les gens qui font
des promotions qui permettent à des gens
comprennent que pourrait pas les moyens
d' habitude de se payer une console de
pouvoir d'achat bien sûr du gouvernement
bah oui c'est normal
tu as eu les langues à savoir faire mais
c'est pas de la faute de lancer je suis
désolé mais moi j'aime beaucoup chez
moneyweek nc10 deuil après je vais ses
actions après je vais à gifi j'aime
beaucoup lidl j'aime beaucoup les
produits déjà j'adore ce qu'ils font
parce qu'ils aident les gens qui sont un
peu et pas cher c'est bien là ils sont
coupables à 100 200 300 personnes bien
sûr qu'ils sont coupables comment ne pas
être coupable on est en pleine pandémie
on sait qu'elle coronavirus on sait que
faut pas réunir les gens et là ils
proposent des consoles à 81 15 euros et
mathieu joue sur le malheur des gens à
orgeval les mecs à côté ils ont tous
voulu offrir des consoles à leurs
enfants ou à leurs proches ou même à eux
à 95 man à 5h10 du matin ils étaient
déjà devant la porte à 5h10 du matin
dans gaza s'appelle jouer avec le
malheur des gens et ça ne va parler de
leurs enseignes lidl est stable vient
passer lidl même une semaine avant ça
s'est bien passé tu n'as pas à faire ça
pendant ce mois une crise sanitaire de
réunir autant de gens les gendarmes y
sont venus au final ait eu des gaz
lacrymogènes
au final les deux gendarmes ils sont
gazés même tout seul et c'est pas bon du
tout combien de consoles qui avait
dedans
30 40 il n'y en avait pas pour tous ces
gens là et c'est à ce moment là tu fais
tu fais des tirages au sort urien sont
bénins mais moi je veux bien faire des
promotions men idole qui est un grand
groupe allemand qui ouvre des magasins
qui sont de plus en plus jolie
ils n'ont pas besoin de faire venir 500
personnes à orgeval pour s'entretuer les
ordis console à 95 balle c'est humilier
les gens c'est jouer avec le maillot des
gens j'ai fait passer l'idée de base
elle est géniale
le seul tort c'est de ne pas avoir
anticipé à dire qu'ils ne sont pas dix
contient une pâte à tartiner qui est un
homo les gens se ruent sur le truc donc
évidemment quand ça être une console
mais ils ont 80 euros non il aurait le
temps à sortir été le plan barre système
de sécurité faire rentrer les gens au
compte gouttes
et puis c'était les premiers arrivés les
premiers c'était hors jeu grâce à des
arrangements
78 n'importe quel mode climatique ils
ont confondu la province y aller la
chercher la console ans michel mr bah
moi je moi je trouve ça incroyable en
plus ils l'avaient annoncé que c'est
annulé la promotion les jeux sont quand
même venus horizons tels qu'ils ont été
longs et fréquents pas qu'il habitait à
23 heures c'est la famille recettes je
vide d'un exemple complètement con
d'hommes à quand un accident encore si
l'on sait sur la voie opposée parce que
les gens ralentissent pour garder et wap
accusé le mec qui a eu l'accident de la
navette ou pas pour le truc 10 des
belges ont fait subir complètement con
victime 35% coupat et la soif